or support the lionesses has been
pouring in from all quarters they've
been messages of support from both the
prime minister and the labour leader and
now they've got the royal seal of
approval as well
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck for tonight you've done
amazingly well in the competition and
we're rooting for you all the way
good luck i hope you win bye
and the men's football squad have also
sent their well wishes to the women's
team have a listen
i hope you're enjoying this amazing
journey that you're all on
that's certainly how it's coming across
from the outside
this really isn't a moment for us to be
involved at all but
we did just want to take the time to
wish you the very best for the final
it's going to be an incredible occasion
hope you're all looking forward to it uh
and yeah i'm wishing you all the best to
go out there and get that win
it's been amazing to watch incredible
journey
and hopefully you can go one step
further than we did last year all the
best bring it home everyone will be
watching everyone will be supporting and
hopefully i can see you after with a
trophy come on girls you know leah and
all the lionesses everyone's proud of
you you've been amazing so far go and
enjoy yourselves do us proud and we're
all supporting you good luck
all the best to the lionesses um i'm
going to actually be at the game and
yeah i'm wishing you all good luck and
hopefully you can get the victory i just
want to say all the best in the euros
final fully deserved obviously you've
been fantastic throughout the tournament
gone it's just one more win and
hopefully you can do one better than us
go out there enjoy it that's the most
important thing i feel like enjoy the
game
take it all in and at the end of the
game hopefully you'll be celebrating
together come on england